ich bin chemikerin am pc abwehrzentrum
weil ich nur hier die möglichkeit haben
ein chemiestudium und dass er ausbildung
an der theresianischen media academy zu
kombinieren
ich habe hier viele verschiedene
aufgaben dazu gehört das entwickeln und
optimieren von methoden zur
identifikation und detektion von
atomaren biologischen und chemischen
gefahrstoffen sowie die ausbildung von
abc abwehr soldaten in technischen und
chemischen grundlagen hier und im
internationalen umfeld
es gehören auch schießausbildung auf
verschiedenen waffen oder szenarien
trainings dazu außerdem habe ich die
möglichkeit an auslandseinsätzen und
übungen teilzunehmen